però mi che si fa caldo per bastano bene
tutti i like ragazzi grazie grazie
grazie di like fantastico questo vuole
vivere spetta a a
abbiamo finito però questa è la vedova
di vita più per 3 2 mentre lavate
coriste finale tratti miei capezzoli
manca solo il mio e dai eccoci e dai è
bene sempre seguite al power che borderi
salute antonio salutandomi alle una di
notte noi a casa nostra neanche le otto
che si era possiamo fare specie la
bambina sopra insomma appena tornati da
lì per adesso facciamo facendo un
livello bella the young family come si
giocano mai giocato questa sera abbiamo
avuto delle frecciatine madonna dove si
gioca investirà di di pac man si giocano
le frecce belli jean o mito hamas è
importante anche nel proprio impersonare
una famiglia di cinesi italiano de sac
uniti fermano cinese è vero come noi non
devo fare la viola ho già vinto guarda è
bravo non fatela qualche secondo me deve
arrivare all'altro e che poi senza
perdere tutte le parti della macchina la
patente o chiudere il sangue forte che
c'è l'orgoglio non ha una gamba a caso
completa della camera lo 0 0 100 dove è
stato il cannone perché ci sono i
cannoni perché a divenire metrò si
baciano basta passare in mezzo ma prof
fast and furious versione asiatica
cinese rende il bullpen di burghley ma
non sono capaci è fa tutto da solo fa
ma sono morti ma secondo me quello che
sbaglia il principio del essere
prevedibile che tu che ci fai un po di
zig zag così perché cannoni pensi ma non
solo qua stai facendo è un fenomeno nei
giochi tomic e stefano riguardo bravo
non sono presenti sul palco metti una
cosa ragazzi usano allacciare le cinture
sicurezza poi bisogna rea 40 elementi
allora perché siamo spesso al 36 matri
ecco fino a mano state una scatola
schiavo si fa dell'imprevedibilità vai
cos'è la cosa vedere gara che voglio il
replay su questo punto ha già fatto se
livello tre volte ovest in larghe dei
rapaci
ha detto quasi esplodono perché è quello
questo è un infame che ti sarà la via
col pick up come settimana non c'è pure
il nostro e non sai che cosa dire dei
pezzi di merda
io ti giuro che era una battuta non
sapevo esistenti a livello mora di
livello 2 minuti è arrivato in città
porti la bambina al dottore è fatta a
fini to stop order e proprio tabani e
bam bam in adozione sulle cose che
esplodono se non sbaglio oddio ho un
camion c'era sul c'era un camion
assordata morti non c'è niente
poi voglio bello il suo sportello
portale automatico nuove generazioni ma
se non tagliano sessuale sono incagliati
aspettano qua c'è più perfetto bravo e
dati veloce vi sono ancora essere ancora
vivo se ancora la nostra ma non andava
avanti fra dove vale niente sei morto
casa squadra basta storia ma si sa la
nascar civile non ci vengo tutto
qualcuno fa cosa e successo la bara è un
altro luce per atmosfera e per i porno
come di trex ecco tony hawk down
[Musica]
sky john le theme studio grafico è si
son fede su fini se ci sono anche le
ventole quelli di è più il lecce 3d ma
non ci posso rispetto estensiva sta roba
tu hai già fatto o torchia [ __ ] e va p
cadono sti cosi non sapevo io ragiono
zio a dritto poi mai diritto mite ma non
c'eravate territorio ma anche frase
ambigua e appena detto vai su carte su
carte le fal di come fai tu no no no lui
e lo spazio è morto miopi che ad essere
in tuba monet briac bellissimo e ha
premuto sul palo a caso still alive bici
che hai fatto ci ha sporcato come al
solito è caduta la fifa bravo salvo
bravo o perfetto a lecce quelli gialli
sono infami perché ci può di gialli non
sono check point è solo progress
praticamente è sono solo gli arancioni
che ti che ti fanno da c'è poi un pink e
scoiattoli brevi fanta non è buona ma
non farli placement va bene faccio lo
stesso la pro sesto
[Musica]
siamo facendo un placement baby fanta
che eruttate come la madonna baby fanta
line e bona ma all 80 ragazzi ogni
100.000 like sto video con gli centomila
fi con cattedra come è morto la faccia
del bambino non seguito il mio padre
nella pace fa impennare non lo so non
sws quanti quanti pasti per indica
veramente sta giocare da programmare per
dire no bravo stefano sono dire che a me
è bastato camere migliaia gira e rigira
tutte donne
200 soldati che ti dà
diceva 230 di matiga si era mai visto
livello nella m di me la godo quella che
ti sei giusto schiantate un attimo
aspetto leva del prezzo livello
affanculo
ma ce l'ha il no se la bici e dagli il
vero un po di fari tower heist a volta
la finiscono adesso mi sento mi sento
carico vinco io no con giandon allora
che cazzo solo con l'arancione dopo
stiamo prendendo a fare che ti dice dove
andare altrimenti ubriachi simone a vela
a te l'ha detto qualche ti senti si
impenna sei [ __ ]
c'è poi sono cominciati qualche asca
tutto vada atto sono fenomeno vai ok io
insomma posto
che i gesti cosi tutti i muri occhio io
capisco io di all i suoi diverso è
quando si aggirava morto e non solo
anche andar dritto in faccia a faccia a
faccia per fare la faccio
ok ora di liberare bene il centro del
giudice le lame dietro io sono più la
legge va bene anche un robusto non solo
piacere
ho perso con mio
[Musica]
oggi roger streep
cos'è sta roba di ordinario non ho
parole non fate tipo sembra viaggio del
100 del corpo umano
ok sono ci sono diano impariamo non ti
abbiamo visto morire tranquillo poi è
morto ma di qui sgomma di latte caso
sicula che me l'ha fatto fare prima
bastardo certo magari non perderò mio
figlio in questa pur dunque sotto in
giro non tutti convinti di questo credo
che dispone il figlio conto scemo non ci
voglio credere
ragazzi questo teheran ciucci perché si
sparano occhio veloce prima che ti
sparano addosso non ci voglio credere
quindi se alzare di passare qua le
scendere e salire a passare al punto
notte c'è uno spazietto guarda che culo
se puoi avere così culo che nei
videogiochi non ho parole ha tentato
tutto dai ragazzi c'è poi questa sì che
è successo a inter fetti l'altro il
figlio nelle more
è riuscito anche a farlo è morto il
figlio loro sito occhio gli haqqani di
casini incani preciso non fate così
acuto della società stava andando avanti
nel livello a caso passerà all'esterno
dall'ex medico 22 santa salita che hai
fatto un pelo alla lama che mi anche a
chi serve davvero
no no c'è poi c'è un input è un imbuto
questo aiuta
l'ho preso dovevo uscire e cos'è sta
roba le ciambelle dai pirati nel bus
frate ha spartito il pianto di un po di
rincorsa di sirigu devo fare di lin ping
vieni perbene penna molto bravo così
cos'è vincendo miti dopo due palle
queste sono mine o cosa era you are dead
at 6 morti un nuovo micaletto sa cosa
che a me fantastico
ho scelto di fare un altro tentativo di
ban ki moon a suo carico a molla
vabbè meno facile presa l'attore cazzo e
dove la si può fare sta partendo
infoline slalom vada a sinistra leggeri
cazzo c'è qualcuno è riuscito a fare sta
partito giocatore forte ma sicuro ma non
è così finché siamo scemi un tasto per
sganciare il bambino perché guarda ai
ragazzi questa è la vita ragazzi clarin
ci vediamo al prossimo che ad un piede
perché il piede fabius la casa non so
fare ed è per questo ci da giovane possa
sentire il dolore del suo corpo
beh ragazzi ma facciamo vedere queste
barre